well in in in some ways it's altered in
some ways it's changed in other ways
it's remained the same I think a
programs change in x change but two
values that really don't change I mean
people's our concern for other people or
people's understanding of what the
Constitution is really about or and the
Bill of Rights and their devotion to it
maybe it changes and that we see a time
when those rights may be may be
threatened more than they have been in
at other times but in the concern that I
see on the floor of the United States
Senate among Democrats among Republicans
there's a very still cork understanding
and awareness that America is just not a
land but it's a promise and that each
time and each generation has to fulfill
the the challenges of the time and the
promise of America I think when I first
arrived in the United States Senate it
was primarily in knocking down walls of
discrimination we still have a ways to
go but we were looking then after
passing Medicare Medicaid higher
education at that time now there are
different challenges both in terms of
trying to protect constitutional rights
still in terms of education and health
care and also in terms of how we make an
end to war so the issues themselves
might change the institution itself has
altered and changed probably the most
dramatic change has been a sort of the
power of money in in politics I'm
long-standing a supporter of public
financing I think people ought to be
accountable to their constituents and
not accountable to the the contributors
but that's still a battle that has to be
a work through in the in the Congress
but I think this what what is left now
in terms of when I first arrived and now
still is
more important than what divides us what
what remains the same